wow that moon night trailer did not
expect to like a moon night trailer
enough to talk about it on my youtube
channel yet here i am here we are which
is kind of a good news bad news scenario
for some of us out there the fact of the
matter was i was i was all ready i was
hunkering down like okay time to talk
about cobra kai season four the fate of
the valley depends on us the time is now
all right let me just check youtube for
a second oh moon night trailer and now
here we are i'm gonna talk about that
cobra kai season four will have to wait
for a couple days but that is the way
and this trailer is this trailers that
that meme with hawkeye you know the one
don't give me hope that because i dare
to hope for moon night it looks pretty
sweet especially in a world where i
haven't really given a [ __ ] about moon i
just i i haven't you know because i'm
not i try not to be petty it's small
don't be petty it's a waste of time and
energy but when it comes to video games
sometimes i can be what can i say story
time we all love story time quick story
time you know marvel heroes that we
write
us we people who played marvel heroes we
loved marvel heroes it was so much fun
midtown monday baby my brother and i
used to do that all the time would max
out a new character's level and
sometimes in marvel heroes you would
have these events these things if you
log in at a certain time or you did a
certain thing you get a random free
character token a character for free how
fun is that my brother pulled moon
knight
randomly
probably 11 to 12 times i feel like i'm
being modest at that point so in terms
of random i'm sure it is random like
magic cards and a magic card pack are
random you have commons all the way to
your foil mythic rares you're more
likely to pull some of the commons and
you are the foil mythic writers pretty
sure moon knight was one of the commons
and you know respect and support for my
brother's like
he called him the boo knight
so when i heard there was a moon night
series i was like the blue nights and i
started pulling moon knight a lot you
know so something about moon night where
i was like oh that's right
oh those times i didn't get doctor doom
or spider-man or something so it's like
all right boo knight trailer why not wow
that trailer looks really good my love
for this trailer comes from the fact
that it doesn't really feel like an mcu
series not that an mcu series or movie
or bad they're not they're reliably
entertaining i have fun with them but
this looks like something else this
looks like a psychological thriller
until the end when you start seeing
capes and puddlings and that one shot it
was pretty sweet shot
comic book flavor right there i do
appreciate that but the scenes with moon
knight when he shows up and the capes
and where it starts looking like a
superhero show kind of felt out of place
to the rest of the trailer that's how
much the rest of this trailer doesn't
really look like an mcu show in that
daredevil kind of way you know it's like
fringe daredevil was mcu and it wasn't
it kind of was it's it's very confusing
point is like daredevil is one of those
shows that i could go to my
ex-girlfriend who doesn't give her she
shouldn't give two [ __ ] about superhero
movies or shows she doesn't care about
marvel she doesn't care she was much
more artsy than i am we still joke about
it to this day but there are superhero
movies and shows that i can still be
like
you i think you would like them the boys
even daredevil because daredevil though
it was about a lawyer who dressed up and
fought crime at night had much more
going on than just a guy who dressed up
and fought crime at night point is moon
night looks like it could be if i dare
to hope
that kind of feeling a psychological
thriller that is in the mcu world but
it's a psychological thriller first and
foremost
don't give me hope and i'm not gonna
front i did not come up with this i saw
it in the comments section of the
trailer but that comment right there you
are a legend because it's completely
true we are in phase four of the mcu
we're dealing with the mind-bending mind
twisting concept of the multiverse
alternate realities and it looks like
the biggest mind [ __ ] mind job that's
coming to the mcu is moon knight just
didn't expect that i think that's really
cool totally worth talking about is it
lost on me the irony of the fact that i
haven't done a video on hawkeye nor have
i actually seen the hawkeye series yet
no i'm thinking about it right now as
i'm talking about moon night or is the
trailer for moon night have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
don't give me hope